[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce vaccin moi j'ai pas eu le plus vite
j'ai eu le vaccin Johnson qui a failli
me tuer le coeur j'ai eu quand opération
depuis le 3 janvier de cette année
et je ne voulais pas donner le samedi
mars que je l'accomplissais pas mon
travail mais je ne savais pas non plus
que Monsieur Macron n'était pas vacciné
je ne savais pas non plus que la plupart
des mamans du gouvernement n'était pas
et je ne savais pas que nombre important
dans mes collègues députés n'étaient pas
non plus
[Musique]
c'était l'époque où Monsieur se fait
Macron Boris Johnson a tous les autres
et même il y avait pas la guerre encore
le président de la Russie peut-il
descendait leur bras blanc
on faisait une injection pour pousser
tout le monde
[Musique]